[Music]  you caused quite a stir when you shaved  off that much yeah yeah as a field but  it's a little cold it's just a little  cold the bloody thing is everybody was  like like they got so used to the  mustache that now I walk around with no  mustache they don't recognize me anymore  so I got a couple days of anonymity  which is nice now with that for the  character is it because you have busted  for work yeah yeah we we may see  different side of jazz I thought you  know how these chases maybe I'll grow on  I'll go on and he can get rid of his  yeah I bet you miss he can't catch  crumbs anymore I'll tell you mad it was  warm well if you have a beard on a  motorcycle it's very warm Justin said  now that you shaved it off he's thinking  about growing a beard to do the opposite  I think I'll be awesome I mean look that  guy can do no wrong this is one of those  beautiful men you've ever seen in their  life  [Music]  you